is it important to set goals for
yourself so if you pick up any business
book or you follow any of the experts
you'll often hear how important it is
and set goals everybody tells you got to
set goals you set goals for yourself and
your business to have success but
there's a new wave of people led by guys
like leo babauta from zen habits who
don't do goals who don't like goals is
it goals restrict their freedom and
their creativity and they get more stuff
done they find where they don't have
goals and so I thought I'd weigh on it
in this video because one thing I know
is that what gets measured gets managed
and that when you have a goal you're
much more likely to hit it you're much
more likely to pass your own
expectations you're much more likely to
push for something when you have a goal
here's an example let me pull out my
pocket I use a Fitbit this is it here I
have a daily goal today is a it's just
past noon and if can you see that I
don't know if you can see that it's just
past noon I have fifteen thousand steps
my daily goal I set for myself was I
wanted 20,000 steps ever since I got
this thing I'm taking an insane number
of steps because I know that I'm
tracking it and tracking it and said in
a goal my first school is 20,000 steps a
day I wanted to blow past it in my
business I wanted to beat the guy at my
agency for the number one YouTube
channel and I blew past it and so having
these goals helps me succeed it helps me
push myself further than I would in some
seminars that I've done I would ask
people to hold their breath for as long
as they could to hold your breath as
long as you can and they would time it
and at some point they would all right
they've lost their breath and then I
asked him okay I want you to hold your
breath for five seconds longer and we'll
get out there watch or the clocks and
then do it and everybody could do it
everybody could hold their breath for
five seconds longer yes I'm again asked
and hold their breath for five seconds
longer everybody could do it again why
the first time I asked them said it for
as long as you can as long as you can
physically hold your breath and yet
everybody could go a little bit more
because they had a goal another example
ask people to raise our hands as high as
they could all right raise your hand as
high as you can reach for the stars
raises how your hands as high as you can
and people would always be able to raise
it just a little bit higher the next
time if I
sent you to say beat that record because
they had a goal and so I find goals are
extremely helpful but the caveat is you
have to know where you're going when you
have a plan when you know what you want
to accomplish having goals will help you
get there faster but if you don't know
what you want to do if you don't have a
plan then you're going down the wrong
path right you can get down the wrong
path a lot faster but it will help you
because you're going down the wrong path
and I think that we all have these
moments in our life whether they last
for days weeks months a year where we we
do have absolute clarity we know exactly
what we want to have happen in our life
and we set out into execution mode and
when you're in that mode Bulls will help
you go to help you get there faster help
you reach for your your best self and
push you beyond where you thought you'd
be able to go but we also have these
moments where we don't know what we want
right you don't have that clarity you
look at your life and say yeah this is
kind of boring I don't want to do what
I'm doing right now I see creativity I
seek difference and they're the goals
that you set for yourself won't help you
as much that's where you need to follow
your flow find that excites you explore
say yes and you can't plan it out as
well and so I find I can understand both
camps I understand the guys who say you
got to set goals and send the guys who
say you don't set any goals and I think
the real valence lies in embracing both
of them when you have that absolute
certainty you set goals when you don't
know what you want to do you don't set
goals and you go on and explore so in
the context of this book because this
video is about supposed to be about me
write my book I find that goals help me
in that there's deadlines for things so
the publishers giving me a deadline I
have to have it done by January and
submitted to them and I set little mini
deadlines for myself every week I'm now
in editing mode I'm walking the whole
foods right now and every week and want
to get at least one chapter edited and
done so that's one less um I get in
there you know I grab my smoothie
sometimes a lunch and I got I start
editing and I want to not have to leave
until I've edited my chapter and so
setting those timelines in those goals
helps me accomplish what my specific
goal is to write the book a lot easier
okay let's get to your questions I seem
to get a lot of these spikes where I ask
the questions I get a ton and then I
forget to ask the questions the next
time and I don't
get a line and the next we get a lot
again so we're in a law we're not a low
question day the first one was from Pete
who said audio book suggestion connect
with the national library services for
the blind they'll record your book for
you and make it accessible the only to
the blind community but other readers
thanks Pete really appreciate that on
all of the marketing stuff promotion
stuff again because we're so far out of
it actually being released that's not
really on my mind yet my mind is focused
on getting the book finished written
edited out the door but I appreciate all
the feedback and suggestions you guys
have for the marketing side once it's up
and to the publisher I will be focusing
all my efforts then on figuring out the
marketing side next up new future
builder as always appreciate your
answering the questions and the
questions of so many others shows you
know how to offer value to us thanks man
appreciate that I'm curious as to why
the publisher takes an entire year to
put the book out our most publishers
that way and if not I'm assuming they
had the most leverage despite the wait
time how did the time of release affect
how you wrote the book in terms of
keeping things time relevant it was a
fantastic question one that honestly
frustrates me I think it frustrates a
lot of authors why does it take so long
I think in general big companies have a
hard time keeping up with the pace of
entrepreneurs a lot of the brands that I
work with we talk about projects and
they talk about all the teams they need
to involve and the timelines like it's
gonna take you that long are you kidding
me i could get that done the week and so
it's the nature of dealing with a big
company i have yet to see a huge company
that just works insanely fast and so I
don't honestly know what happens in that
year I'm assuming it's a bunch of
editing and revisions and deciding what
stays in the book and what gets cut and
working on the book cover I don't see
why that has to take a year but I'm not
the publisher I don't understand their
business fully and so I'm just trusting
in the process and then using that time
instead to come market and to talk to
you guys and make videos and in terms of
the timing being relevant a lot of the
stuff that i like talking about and that
is in the book is timeless stuff go back
to the top of this piece talking about
goals
is no goals that stuff is relevant in 20
years it was relevant 20 years ago and
my aim as much as possible is to create
content that lives that lives forever I
want that to be part of my legacy now
there are some things social media wise
technology wise internet why's that that
change very frequently and there's not a
ton of that in the book my specific aim
again was to make it something that when
you look at this in 5 years 10 years 20
years ninety-five percent of principles
are still relevant applicable and so it
doesn't really impact how I write the
book so much as my frustration are you
wanting to get the book out and to you
guys and to having an impact on the
world and then last questions from Sam I
agree about wanting to do things
yourself and feeling put out from people
not being able to reach you at your
level I immediately find this hard to
deal with because there have been many
times that I felt that tail tail
excitement of something starting to come
to fruition only to find those i'm
working with apply themselves half-assed
it's that's my motivation and I feel
like I get knocked back a few steps is
just just a situation telling me I've
chosen among people to work with that I
should keep adventuring for the right
people to surround myself with thank you
sir Sam appreciate that notice that
you're a bt a 67 on that that's awesome
you're ahead of my BTA because I had a
weekend that I took off so you might
have the highest BTA of all the
subscribers I think so far so keep on
thank you bro to answer the question
yeah it's super common right at the
beginning of any project everybody is
mega excited ready to go and invariably
people over promise and and under the
liver and they lose their excitement and
it's not not Tom malicious for the most
part it's not people feel like they can
get something done and then the cane and
they're lying to you and they're they're
trying to you know put them up with
something that they're not actually I
don't think that's the case for most
people most people just are not that
committed in general most people don't
follow through and most people don't
have the hustle just in general and so
finding those people those right people
to work on the project is really
important it's a couple things that
might help one I would try to find the
project that I am so excited about that
no matter who I'm working with if it
doesn't work out i will just want to
find somebody else to work with because
i love it so much so you know i love
working on these videos as in Jack i
love i love my youtube channel for you
guys i have a team that helps me now it
started with just me and now there's
five of us who work on the channel and
if everybody quit if everybody stopped
doing it if everybody said this is too
much you know or they lost in motivation
their excitement their energy I would
still keep going I would find
replacements I would build a new team
because I love doing it and if your
happiness in a project is dependent on
other people's enthusiasm then
that's a problem that you would probably
want to look at right the project that
I'm doing the book the videos my company
the new company i bought i would do
regardless of the team i would build a
team i build a new team if the right
people weren't already in place and so I
think you have to have that level of
enthusiasm and excitement yourself to
keep yourself motivated and they keep
the team going as well and then turns to
bring on the right people it's so
important and it's understanding
different motivations for different
people and understanding what roles they
could be because some people are just
not great partners some people have
great skills might be great employees
might be great contributors might be
great consultants but they're not
partnership material what I always try
to do as much as possible with any role
that I make is to have people start on a
small scale and then see how they do if
I'm working with somebody in some kind
of partnership capacity it's usually
because I've worked with them before on
something smaller where I've really
enjoyed their work we enjoy how we work
together and I obviously would love
their commitment level so I wouldn't
just go into a relationship where it's
hey I oh and a half you own half let's
start this thing up and it's amazing if
I was working with somebody who was
newer to me that I have a work with
before I would absolutely have some kind
of earning clause where they might be
able to earn up to a certain percentage
in the business but we're starting off
working on a project basis where they
have to put their sweat into it and make
sure there is something that but they're
committed to and will succeed with I do
the same thing when I'm hiring people
for my team I'll hire them on one small
project as a trial see how well we work
together you know everybody who works me
Kristine who's that in this video you
know we worked on a small trial before
and she was awesome and she /
deliverance it I have to have Christina
on my team and that's why we're still
working together and now we brought her
husband on the help at it as well hey
Sam how you doing and so I think it's
really important I think people put too
much stock into what's on the resume
they put too much faith into an
interview they put too much faith into
the initial
segment we're really what you need to do
is start testing people start working
with people start on a small scale and
then start building it up whether it
become an employee whether we come apart
in your business make sure you test
small and build up that's my advice
that's it for the questions it's a short
day today so for you guys you have
questions you want me to answer leave it
in the comments below ideally somehow
related to the topic today which was
about setting goals versus not setting
goals and of course if you have a
question about my book your book the
book writing process leave it below and
I'll do a video reply next week and
question of the day I would love to know
what you guys think about wolf setting
isn't important do you set goals is it
always important in your life do you see
moments where it's not so important I
love to hear your thoughts leave in the
comments below thank you guys continue
to believe I am off to edit and I'll see
you soon